wow
a weird time controls do we got any of
those another seven minute game but
we've done seven minutes oh
four plus eight oh another four plus
eight wow you guys are pretty good at
this you guys are pretty good at this
uh fun guy was a donator so let's play
fungi
i'm a fun guy this guy i don't know he
sounds fun
he might be a fun guy let's try to play
him in a game of chess
um oh and do i not have the did the did
the alert go through hopefully you guys
saw it
let me make sure one thing uh
alert wow where is it
box okay where is the alert box oh it's
just all over the middle of the screen
all right let's put this way up here
boom
alert box and let's play i'm a fun guy
and let's play e5 again
let's play e5 again french defense was
requested
uh french defense might be possible ah
one of these bishops c4 players
wow bishop's opening where did this guy
learn this one
ah d4 right a way hmm
all right well let's take this one we'll
see where this leads us
[Music]
over here put this here do some stuff
and we're back
okay so he develops tonight okay we'll
just uh protect our pawn here
no big deal against fungi uh okay and
he's kind of ignored that this pawn is
here so we will
see what's up here uh nachman's in
gambit
holy cow the night is hanging the night
is hanging
what are you doing oh it's a bishop oh
it's a bishop
boop king of six king f6 so this is our
second neckman sin of the day
and i think we've learned our lesson so
if here i now know the move is bishop to
e7
the main move is here this should be
good for
uh white insane people might consider d4
or b takes hopefully my opponent doesn't
play any of these moves because they're
all impossible for black to solve over
the board
and we'll see what happens here kf6 is
the critical line
um and it's you know it's a lot of fun
a lot of computers don't even have a
good understanding of this position
it's just craziness it's just the wild
wild west over here
the problem is if you go back to e8
white plays rookie one
uh takes the knight with the rook and
then just simply plays bishop to g5 and
brings the other rook in and no matter
what you do
like maybe you can survive as black but
it's really hard
so yeah this is i mean it's definitely a
fun one it sounds like there's a lot of
people that haven't seen this
neckline gambit before yeah i mean it's
a ton of fun uh
you give up two pieces you probably will
get one back
this is uh okay so now i have to play
just a series of accurate moves here
rook e1 i cannot move my knight because
then the bishop comes here
so i need to prevent that idea
okay so now i've prevented this idea
and now white will decide how to take i
would expect them to take with the queen
where i then need to very carefully
remember if it's king f7 or d5 right
away
only one of them will suffice and i
honestly cannot remember
so we'll figure this all out together
check the donut page
okay very cool very cool um refresh
oh holy cow dude you did all of it
dude dude
you did all of it oh my gosh
mega blaziken oh you beast
it's over we did it we did it
holy cow dude
you're incredible thanks so much man oh
my gosh
oh my gosh
he did it he did it guys he did it
we reached our goal dude you're the best
oh my gosh you're the best the kids at
nance will be so happy
um oh man that's really cool
oh that's really cool uh oh wait though
oh did you guys hear that
oh no you guys you guys hear something
did you guys what is what's going on
here
what's going on oh my gosh there's
fireworks
it's a celebration it's a celebration we
did
it wow wow we did it
we did it
wow very cool very very cool thanks so
much man for real that's really really
awesome when you did that
holy cow
it's not awesome it takes e4 which is
not the right move but no i don't know
what to do
oh my gosh okay run away run away me run
away
i just need to run away mega blaze again
he's the hero
i don't care if i i don't care if i'm
dying here i don't care
you know we did it we did it
we did it
oh my gosh this is a good move i was
gonna put my king there no i can't
you're still gonna go here
oh no no no okay this is gonna be good
it's gonna get tough uh let's make sure
i identify all the threats
regulations here really real deep
[Music]
the fireworks make them come back wait i
still hear the sound i don't
see the fireworks wait there might be a
new show well another show
another show wow those are the coolest
colors
those are the coolest colors
stonewall would be good if it wasn't so
bad yeah except for the being bad part
uh the stonewall for teaching kids
though i've learned if you're a kid
in scholastics like every scholastic kid
should play the stonewall
man does it win when kids just play the
stonewall man doesn't win
whoa that was a big one that was a
really big one
that was really big
oh my gosh let's clean yeah
yeah yeah i took a queen
very cool we did it
yeah there was a pin so i've actually
seen this mistake a few times already
today
this thing's pinned so he's like okay
you can't take me but the king the king
got there so what was once super mega
dangerous it will now
be pretty easy ready
sound appreciative
is coming in here that's another piece
though got him
we got him all right that's the end of
the show that's the end of
the fireworks show so uh
boom dude blaziken that's really cool
man that's really cool
the program is super awesome and uh and
now the kids will be able to get it
going
so hopefully by the next time i stream
two we'll be able to announce we got
another really cool one
uh another program that we're gonna be
trying to raise funds for so
super super awesome man for real really
[Music]
cool